Salut Romain
Dis donc, fait voir tes oreilles. Elles ont une drôle de forme, non ?
Qu'est-ce que tu fais comme sport ?
Romain: De la polyphonie, je suis imouvriniste amateur
Ah ouais, c'est bizarre on dirait on peu des ...des tranches de Copa. Nan ?
*Générique*
Vous connaissez le rugby ?
Est-ce-que vous aimez le rugby ?
Non parce que tout le monde aime le rugby
Ses valeurs, ses combats, ses héros, ses chevauchées, ses troisièmes mi-temps, ses calendriers...
Bon, mais est-ce que vous avez remarqué la particularité des joueurs de rugby?
J'veux dire, à part le fait qu'ils soient tous taillés comme des persos de Street Fighter,
qu'ils jouent avec un ballon qui rebondit n'importe comment,
et qu'ils mangent des biscottes chelous?
Bah, leurs oreilles enfin!
J'ai récemment eu la chance de pouvoir côtoyer
de très près quelques uns des plus beaux spécimens ORL
de la planète ovale au tournoi des Six Stations.
*musique de fanfare*
En français comme en anglais, on appelle ça poétiquement "des oreilles en chou-fleur".
Bon, même si moi, ça me fait plutôt penser à des eggs mc muffins mais bon...
Ça s'explique en fait par deux autres particularités,
l'une liée au rugby,
et l'autre liée aux oreilles.
Un peu comme la lutte, la boxe, le judo, etc,
le rugby a l'espiègle habitude de taquiner
très fort ce qu'on appelle "le pavillon de l'oreille"
C'est la partie qu'on voit de l'extérieur
Elle est frottée, pliée, malaxée, elle reçoit des coups
Se forment alors des collections de sang
*musique de la série Dexter*
Une collection de sang, en fait ça veut dire un hématome.
Un othématome même. C'est à dire un hématome de l'oreille qui se forme entre la peau et le cartilage
Et il se trouve que les hématomes de l'oreille ne sont pas des hématomes comme les autres.
D'abord parce que contrairement à ceux que vous vous faites quand vous vous cognez un membre
ils se résorbent très mal.
Ensuite parce qu'ils ont tendance à se fibroser, voire se calcifier,
c'est à dire qu'ils restent en place, ils durcissent et ça modifie la forme de l'oreille.
Quand ils sont mal ou pas du tout soignés, ces hématomes peuvent entraîner
une chondrite, c'est à dire une inflammation du cartilage
Et une périchondrite, c'est à dire une inflammation des tissus qui entourent le cartilage.
Ces hématomes ont aussi la fâcheuse tendance d'empêcher le sang d'irriguer correctement le cartilage
qui finit par mourir, donc se déformer, ce qui donne cet aspect caractéristique d'une espèce de patisserie
dans laquelle on aurait mis trop de levure.
Alors la question que vous allez poser c'est :
"Mais alors pourquoi tous les joueurs de rugby n'ont pas les oreilles en chou fleur?"
Non... t'as pas heu...
Romain: Ah si si, heu pourquoi tous les joueurs de rugby...
C'est trop tard !
D'abord parce que tous les postes ne sont pas exposés de la même façon.
Ensuite, parce qu'il existe des protections qui sont plus ou moins efficaces
comme le casque, par exemple, que je portais personnellement au cours de ma carrière,
comme les bandes d'élastoplast qu'on entoure autour de la tête
et qu'on peut même parfois compléter de demi-balles de tennis pour bien isoler les oreilles.
Ensuite, parce qu'il y a des traitements.
Immédiatement après l'apparition d'un hématome, on peut mettre une poche de glace dessus
pour limiter le saignement.
Un médecin peut ensuite faire une incision au niveau de l'oreille
pour drainer le sang ou l'aspirer avec une grosse aiguille.
Après ça, il faut appliquer un pansement qui comprime bien l'oreille
pour éviter que le saignement reprenne.
Certains p'tits malins utilisent même des sangsues pour aspirer le sang de leurs oreilles...
...mais les spécialistes ont quelques doutes sur la réelle efficacité de la méthode.
La dernière solution consiste à avoir recours à la chirurgie plastique pour remodeler le pavillon.
Ça reste purement esthétique parce que les oreilles "en chou-fleur" ce n'est pas dangereux
Ça peut juste être un petit peu embêtant si la déformation bouche le conduit auditif externe
ce qui diminue l'audition.
Bon, pour la chirurgie, il vaut mieux attendre la fin de carrière,
histoire de pas avoir tout à recommencer au bout de six mois.
Mais c'est de toute façon assez rare que les joueurs y ait recours,
un peu pour les mêmes raisons qui font qu'ils sont pas plus nombreux à se protéger.
Oui, les oreilles "en chou-fleur", c'est à la fois un signe d'appartenance à la grande famille du rugby
mais aussi une sorte de trophée, qui indique qu'on a été un valeureux combattant. *cris de joie en fond*
Oui, alors heureusement que ça touche que les oreilles, quand même.
Et heureusement que c'est des choux-fleurs aussi.
*clic*
*clic
*hennissement de cheval*
Voilà, DTC, c'est fini pour aujourd'hui,
on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo,
d'ici là... mollo sur les biscotes
Mettez-vous bien, et surtout, portez-vous bien.
*Chanson en fond*
*Générique*